build it draw it play Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people this is
building Pinocchio is created by
students from Victoria University of
Wellington by modifying a lamp and
adding animatronic elements its actions
are driven primarily by Arduino and
image processing software OpenCV which
searches for faces with its webcam and
once it finds a face it attempts to
follow it as if trying to maintain eye
contact feyo Johnson's latest miniature
kinetic sculpture is called the an
American eddakath on Dolores it walks on
20 separate legs that move in a fluid
wave-like sequence it incorporates 122
moving parts and is produced by the
on-demand 3d printing service Shapeways
box is an ongoing series of unusual
photos from Belgium based 354
photographers crafted out of cardboard
filled with miniature furniture each
diorama was built around the perspective
of the camera to ensure the scenes had
the right angle and depth the bird buggy
was created by University of Florida
engineering student Andrew gray to keep
his parrot occupied and quiet the
vehicle is controlled by a joystick that
the bird can move in four directions
with its beak and is also equipped with
bump sensors and infrared collision
sensors to keep the bird from getting
stuck once the bird is removed the bird
buggy returns itself to a docking
station utilizing a webcam draw medical
illustrator Emily Evans created a series
of histology plates with the help of her
colleagues in the medical and art fields
she was provided with prepared slides of
various stained and scanned human
tissues and worked with the ceramic
artist to make the plates thyroid bowel
liver bone pancreas esophagus kidney and
testicle 99 steps of progress is a
series of Illustrator
missions that parody the famous march of
progress created by Paris artist
collective mantis a new illustration is
unveiled each day for 99 days and each
design is available for purchase in a
variety of formats including prints
posters t-shirts and hoodies and now for
the guts and gadgets artwork of
madspetersen G Phoebe is a digitally
animated Street are created by UK artist
insa he paints takes a photo and
repaints multiple times to create motion
and then brings it to the net as an
animated gif or Jif plan volume and
noise is an interactive social media
project by Sean Hathaway that consists
of a 30s Philco radio modified to speak
tweets in real time is a group of
musicians from France that make music
using everyday objects here they are
playing Habanera from the classic opera
Carmen
[Music]
engineering student James McVey built
mech base a robotic bass guitar that
consists of four string units on an
aluminum frame here it is playing
hysteria by Muse
[Music]
rap rave is the newest track from West
London MC screw fizzer directed by John
Moore with illustrations by Hattie
Stewart submit your VPS as a personal
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at the brand-new
Vsauce 2 Facebook page
you
you
click here to listen to a brand new
installment of bidipi radio music
created and submitted by you guys also
check out your bidipi an entire video
dedicated to your creations and as
always thanks for watching
destroy them as no matter to Tsar's
older number even if I have to kill the
devil himself
and dancing is good
[Music]
you